as far as characteristics like  unbearable cuteness go I would have to  say the the greasiest  or like the common bamboo lemur is  probably the most adorable thing that  exists on earth their beautiful new  babies they're all the day active bamboo  VOCs are the smallest they like bananas  so we're a good pair right now because I  happen to have a banana this one oh I'm  gonna have to soon  this one's whole head is oh well leave  this bamboo lemurs first of all eat  bamboo they eat the new kind of shoot  that comes out and makes the leaves  they're some of the most cryptic of all  the lemurs cryptic means that they can  disappear in an instant so there was a  reason that nobody had studied them  before I started  they are indeed some of the cutest  animals on earth look at that little  face it's very sweet  you